that's a wrap literally
we will spare you America just hours
after getting ousted from Good Morning
America Amy robach and TJ Holmes packed
on some heavy PDA check out the two all
smiles as Amy raps her arms and legs
around TJ it's been a great week to keep
going and going and going just to enjoy
it yeah the couple enjoyed a day out in
Los Angeles mere hours after their ABC
News exit became official seemingly
unbothered by it all you all already
know this is a competitive bunch
a spokesperson for the network tells E.T
that after several conversations with
Amy and TJ about their options the best
course of action is that they move on
from their former roles at the company
hey good morning
's very unproductive work day at the
office Amy and TJ's workplace romance
broke headlines last November and since
the couples remained strong even
spending the holidays together TJ isn't
that your favorite food
he always gets him in the holiday spirit
why do I tell you things in confidence
how will their departures from GMA
differ
Attorneys at the network are going to be
try to be as Fair as possible in
Amy's case
as this was all spurred because of the
affair they had but their cases are
different they're different individuals
they're different facts there's
different patterns of what happened and
so out of fairness I would assume
um anyone who conducted this
investigation would be looking at both
of these cases separately
as for if they're publicized Affair will
affect their careers looks like they may
have a future on air I think a lot of
it wasn't handled correctly however I do
think their kind of behavior is
something that some employers are going
to be able to look uh past and perhaps
hire them for other positions on air or
elsewhere it is working chaos though it
all somehow figures itself out on
television but behind the scenes yes it
might seem like a madhouse
foreign